bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors l'épidémie de
coronavirus connaît un rebond en france
le nombre de cas d'infection à e est en
hausse constante près de 5500 cas ces
dernières 24 heures on déplore aussi 22
décès si le taux de contamination est en
hausse et parce qu'il y a de plus en
plus de personnes testées mais le virus
n'est pas aussi virulent qu'au cours du
mois d'avril et du mois de mai dernier
est ce qu'on s'alarme plus qu'il ne faut
selon vous alors j'aurai juste nuancer
un petit peu ce qui vient d'être dit en
fait on voit on a des indicateurs
beaucoup plus nombreux que ce qu'on
avait de ceux dont on disposait au moins
2 au mois de mars dernier donc il faut
qu'on cherche beaucoup plus donc de fait
on voit beaucoup plus de gens de positif
et il faut quand même rappeler que
aujourd'hui près d'une personne sur deux
chez les cachets laquelle on trouve du
virus est une personne qui n'est non
symptomatiques mais qui est probablement
en mesure de transmettre le virus donc
ça c'est un message qui est très
important à faire passer donc le nombre
de cas augmente progressivement on a des
données notamment sur la région
parisienne qui montre que les eaux usées
qui on utilise également comme un
indicateur puisqu'elles reçoivent le
virus des populations ces eaux usées
sont de plus en plus positif depuis le
20 juin dont c'est une une recirculation
qu'on voyait à très bas bruit et qui se
renforcent assez clair le virus circule
il a beaucoup circulé pendant les congés
on a parlé des gestes barrières qui
n'ont pas été respectées aussi du
brassage des populations qui est liée
aux congés
ce qui est absolument important à
comprendre c'est que le virus n'est pas
moins virulent quand on cherche beaucoup
plus on trouve beaucoup plus de cas
positifs qu'on en trouvait auparavant et
ça donne faussement probablement
l'impression que le virus est moins
dangereux il a juste que des gens sont
testés de façon massive qu'on trouve
plus de positif est qu'on a
effectivement encore aujourd'hui assez
peu de cas à l'hôpital mais il ya un
point de vigilance important il est
probable que les cas hospitaliers vont
augmenter dans les semaines qui viennent
alors que le virus a priori pas moins
virulent et le nombre de cas augmente
progressivement c'est tout à fait exact
alors un mois peut-être sur au sujet de
la virulence c'est juste pour par
rapporte pour souligner le fait qu'il
n'y a bon entre guillemets que 22 morts
à déplorer sur ces dernières 24 heures
et moins de personnes aussi
dans les services de réanimation les
hôpitaux c'est un fait oui c'est en fait
mais il faut aussi prendre conscience du
fait que les gens qui décèdent
aujourd'hui sont des gens qui ont été
infectés il ya plusieurs semaines
donc on a un décalage entre la situation
on voit aujourd'hui les gens qui sont
infectés aujourd'hui sont des gens qui
soient guériront spontanément dans la
majorité des cas dans les jours qui
viennent soit sont des gens chez
lesquels parce qu'il ya un âge qui le
qui peut l'expliquer ou des facteurs de
comorbidité qui peuvent l'expliquer sont
des gens qui peuvent déclencher des
formes plus gradés qu'on va retrouver
dans les hôpitaux dans les semaines qui
viennent donc faire attention
il ya toujours un décalage entre les
tests qu'on peut faire sur les
populations et les conséquences
sanitaires qu'on pourra trouver dans
quelques semaines donc attention une
lecture qui doit pas être faite en temps
réel sur tous les indicateurs une
réaction peut-être à la dernière sortie
du professeur aoustin qui dit qu'on doit
apprendre à 10 à vivre avec cette
maladie que cette maladie n'est pas plus
mortelle que les autres il souligne que
les taux de mortalité ton en dessous ld
2% qu'en pensez vous le taux de
mortalité dans l'absolu veut pas dire
grand chose pouvait avoir une maladie
excessivement létale mais qui concerne
très peu de personnes vous pouvez avoir
et c'est probablement le cas de lakovic
19 une maladie dont le taux de létalité
quand même significatif mais qui par
contre touche un très grand nombre de
gens locaux final c'est le produit de
ces deux paramètres qui importe et on a
quand même trente deux mille décès en
france déplorer depuis le début de
l'épidémie je pense pas qu'on puisse
dire que c'est sans impact sur la sur la
sur la santé des populations ou
comparable à ce qu'on peut voir avec
d'autres virus la grippe saisonnière en
particulier en france fait moins de
décès comme en a fait aujourd'hui la
cobi 19 donc je pense que c'est un virus
il dit il faut que les messages soient
très claires qui est virulent on a pas
d'évidence on n'a pas de preuves pour
dire que le virus qui circule
aujourd'hui les moins on a la chance
d'avoir des indicateurs qui nous disent
attention le virus circule et ses
messages on doit les intégrer en lice
dans premièrement les gens qui sont
testés positifs doivent s'isoler
il faut les sortir de la population
générale donc il faut les aider à
trouver les bonnes conditions
d'isolement pour qu'ils ne contaminent
pas d'autres personnes ça c'est un
message vraiment essentiel deuxième
chose il faut aller se faire tester si
on a des signes cliniques
si on a été en contact avec quelqu'un d'
infecté ou si par exemple les les
la situation fait que vous devez vous
rendre dans un ehpad ou rencontrer
quelqu'un de fragile
si vous êtes positif il faut prendre des
mesures et il faut casser absolument
remettant les gestes barrière en place
le masque est un des outils de lavage
les mains la distanciation social qu
absolument remettre en place ces
barrières pour bloquer cette résurgence
le plus tôt possible pour ne pas avoir
un hiver et un automne qui seront
difficiles tout simplement parce que les
conditions sanitaires la reprise du
travail vont faire que les gens vont se
retrouver et que le virus risque de
circuler a une nouvelle fois de façon
importante pendant cette période on a
une chance de voir le virus disparaître
de lui même sans qu'on attende par
exemple l'apparition de vaccins alors
c'est une alors c'est très honnêtement
je sais vraiment pas un pari que
geoffrey c'est pas l'expérience qu'on a
pour d'autres d'autres virus de cette
nature là et par ailleurs il faut
insister là-dessus la situation mondiale
et la situation française ne sont pas
identiques on le voit les situations
épidémiologiques en amérique du sud en
particulier aujourd'hui sont
excessivement préoccupantes elles le
sont beaucoup moins
en europe on ad on a des vagues
épidémiques qui sont décalées dans le
monde est un virus qui circulent et qui
re circulera c'est à dire que même si on
contrôle sur un territoire la
circulation du virus
il faudra également surveiller les cas
qu'on appelle d'importation c'est à dire
les gens qui viennent de zones où ils
ont été contaminés et qui viennent faire
du tourisme viennent travailler en
france ou dans l'eau dans différents
pays
donc il ya des mesures à mettre en place
et il est probable que l'hiver en tout
cas l'hiver en europe soit une période
favorable à la circulation du virus donc
on n'entre pas dans la meilleure période
pour la surveillance du virus
on a un taux d'immunisation des
populations qui est faible quoi qu'on en
dise il ya beaucoup de débat là dessus
mais on est très probablement très très
en dessous de ce qu'on appelle
l'immunité de protectrice était très en
dessous de ce taux de protection qui
empêcherait une circulation naturelle du
virus dans les populations
donc effectivement il faut tenir le coup
jusqu'à ce que soit mis en place des
vaccins
sachant que le déploiement des vaccins
est encore est encore un sujet de
discussion et on est dans les phase iii
dans le meilleur des cas donc dans les
phases ont fait la preuve de concept de
l'efficacité du vaccin
il faudra ensuite produire ce vaccin en
doses importantes et surtout le déployer
de façon importante donc le vaccin sera
probablement le ou les vaccins sont
déployés de façon séquentielle va
d'abord vacciner les gens les plus
fragiles ou les pauses exposé avant de
déployer le vaccin dans la population
mais
mon avis non le virus ne va pas
s'arrêter spontanément il ya aucune
raison pour ça vincent maréchal merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur à
l'université de la sorbonne et
spécialiste en virologie
merci beaucoup